hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
super excited i'm pumped right now to be
sat with nigel
nigel is um absolutely killing it in
properties he's got multiple rent to
rents
lease option agreements making 3.2 000
pounds a month
in in profit every single month and also
my brother from zimbabwe originally
right
respect man hey super glad to have you
in the studio thanks for coming down
thank you for having me here samuel
so what's your story then what's your
back story how did you get into property
where did this all start
yeah um basically i came i moved from
luton
to birmingham for university yeah so
when i was at uni
i didn't really like the uni life i
always thought i wanted
um something different something more to
be honest with you
so i started working full-time while i
was at uni
okay and when i got into the working
life
because i just read um rich dad poor dad
yeah so thinking okay if i work
i can save some money invest it into
property because
that's what it was all about yeah um
and then but while i was working i was
it's just got a bit too much
what we didn't make sense i was a stock
controller in uh in a warehouse
okay yeah yeah it was a decent job to be
honest with you but um
it was very like intense 12 hour shifts
yeah sometimes they want blood right
crazy jobs do you want blood crazy you
know okay what's it there
so you got a job alongside uni working
crazy
with the idea to save up money yeah but
not to put it in the bank
and buy a house to live in and pay off
the mortgage because you were a little
bit educated because you read rich dad
poor dad so you knew you wanted to get
into investment
so then what happened so well while i
was working
um so because i was on a computer i used
to always watch
youtube videos and stuff yeah and then i
think the first person i would have seen
was a guy called tony law
but then i watched this video and then
one of the recommended videos
was summary leads and then when i
clicked on there then i just
like it's like i explored the whole new
world of like stuff like rent friends
crazy stuff in 2018 so while i was
working i was just binge watching your
videos too yes
so but at the same time it was like
i'm still at work even though i'm
getting all this knowledge i wasn't
really doing anything about it
yeah like most people yeah yeah i was
just literally working at that time
um came to your crash course in november
2018.
you remember the date yeah because it
was a special moment for me
even though i i even got a vip ticket to
be honest because i was like
you know what i want to be at the front
i want to get as much knowledge as i can
because yeah you inspired me so much
before
through the videos honestly like a lot
of stuff that you've done
it's just like crazy unbelievable so you
spent two days
property and versus crash course played
a small amount yeah it was like what
maybe a hundred pound it if that
honestly less than a hundred pounds yeah
it was now you're on the
now you're on the samuel 365. yeah which
again is less than a hundred pound a
month
it's crazy so what happened then after
the crash goals what happened so after
the crash close
i was like super motivated honestly like
i was crazy like i was going
making viewings um but
so i got my first rent rent but it was a
bad
deal honestly it was a really bad deal i
was still working on that time
yeah um it was a three bed
in this medic in birmingham yeah and
to be fair um i had to put three months
deposit out front
i had to put money for furniture to do
up the house what month was this so this
was like
december so this was just a month after
the crash course not even a month
days after the question is you also i
know you went to the deal finally
extravaganza
as well that must have been early the
following year so that was like
much the following year okay that's why
that's when i booked it for i couldn't
wait that long honestly
but that's the problem i must say though
i mean i'm looking forward to hearing
about what went wrong yeah because i
think that it's important to know that
this
if you just go out with little knowledge
watch some youtube videos have a bash
it's great to have lots of action but
things can go wrong
and that's why i do think it is
important to pay for training
um because you can make money you can
lose money so tell me about that first
dylan smith what happened
so um basically it was a three bed house
which i fought out ten into four beds
yeah
but i could only rent out the three
rooms why
because the the downstairs it the way
the way it was set up it was an open
plan downstairs
yeah if it makes it okay and then
there's a kitchen on its own
yeah so i thought maybe i'm just gonna
partition a wall
um yeah into that place but then the
landlord goes
you can't do that can't do anything not
loudly yeah you're not allowed right so
it was a bad deal
but i was i i was so motivated
at first so i just took it on before yes
yeah do you think as well sometimes when
you're desperate for a deal
yeah you i mean it's a dangerous place
to be in
you know because i mean just generally
when you're desperate i mean i know
you've gone on to do some great things
but
i always say to people don't be
desperate because if you're desperate
for money
people will treat you like a leper
they'll run away from you if you're
desperate for a deal you'll take on a
bad deal you take on the first bad deal
that comes because when you actually
actually know what
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get trained i'm
gonna get lots of deals in front of me
and then i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
pessimistic with the numbers
you know it's a much better place to
come from um how much money did you lose
in total on that first deal
honestly i'd saved up i had ten thousand
pounds saved yeah yeah
um after that still i only had like two
so you lost like eight grand on that
here's the thing though nigel
many people at that point yeah would
have cancelled their training
would have given up and would have said
this doesn't work would have stuck at
their job
and then would have been one of those
trolls i knew it wasn't right for me to
blame you for that
because a i was waiting for training
which was coming yeah so and i
i decided you know what i just want to
take action now yeah
yeah i was just motivated especially
after watching your
financial freedom video i remember
messaged you on facebook
that time i was like dude i'm i want to
quit my job
yeah you know what i mean but you said
okay it's probably not the best idea
to quit your job before you actually get
money coming in
yeah but in my head i was just ah
i was so super like crazy because it you
had opened
like my eyes into a whole different
world of like
how you can get passive income you know
stuff that's not
really um put out there yeah
no that makes it i think i related to
you as well like for me i'm an
instructor
imagine if you're a driving instructor
and you're saying to people everyone you
shouldn't be walking
driving is way better come and drive
driving's easy come and drive and then
people go okay i'll just drive and then
just jump in the lamborghini with no
we've no
instructor and go it's like that's good
that you're taking action it's good that
you listen to me but at the same time
you know it's that kind of contrast
between taking
mad action which you are a crazy action
taker yeah but then at the same time
being careful with your numbers you know
so okay so you lost money on that how do
you feel
i mean i've to be honest i feel good you
felt good when you lost money oh no
sorry at the time
oh no at the time how did you feel
terrible mate yeah i was like
but the thing is um because when i went
to crash course
connected with a few people so i spoke
to some of your students and stuff like
that yes
well i regarded myself as one of your
students anyway um
so we connected so they gave me a bit of
advice yeah good so
a better pep talk i told you don't worry
it's not normal
okay so did you have the keys back then
to the landlord in the end so um
not initially um because there was a six
months break class okay so at least you
honored your work
yeah yeah you honored your word what i
had to do was just rent it out
for that yeah yeah fair enough okay so
that deal weren't terrible yeah you then
did the deal finally extravaganza i know
you had some issues with your girlfriend
as well she wasn't well yeah and
um which we don't have we have to talk
about that um
then what happened like second they'll
go good or bad
good okay i told you about a second
that's when i changed my strategy at
that point
to into essay because okay i just
gained a whole lot of new information
and then so my first deal
uh my first essay deal actually was on
new hall street in birmingham
okay i know this street very well yeah i
know very well do you know the brindley
house building
yes i do yeah yeah that one there i
actually have friends that live in that
same building oh okay yeah yeah or did
yeah well yeah that was my first one at
that time
um rent was about 800. it was really
doing well
um so i kept it there going
and then from then onwards like just so
you pay 800 pounds a month for the
apartment which is not bad
how much how much were you turning over
on that property how much was it
grossing
honestly um it would fluctuate
yeah at times three and a half times
like in in like um august time
you know in the busy periods yeah at
some point
so on average were you making a profit
or what like eight hundred quid a grand
yeah like e01 200 okay okay
so again that deal that was a good deal
yeah you still have that
well i still have the property yeah um
it's not great
it's not going so well because the
pandemic right yeah
okay so basically and this is what i
like about you as well nigel because
you're young but you're constantly
transitioning a little bit so you got
the first deal which was a total flop
disaster then you got some knowledge
about service accommodation for your
second year which was amazing success
pandemic comes it's not amazing you
still got it
but you've really transitioned into a
whole bunch of other stuff lease option
agreements
all kinds of stuff apartments like
different types of rent to rent deals
um and not given up through everything
so talk to me
about the deals that you've done in
total now so how many deals have you got
in total at the moment um
i've got three hmos yeah which are rent
friends
right back in good money yeah how much
they're making uh
two of them 850 plus around there
depending on maintenance is that eight
or is it between the two of them well
each
okay cool sorry per property sorry yeah
right um
and then one of them 700 pounds it's a
three bed townhouse
yeah in um on george street i don't know
if you know
where george street is it's a townhouse
called
extra reception rooms so we turn that
into hmo like amazings
um and then go a couple essays like six
uh flats six flats yeah yeah okay wow
but it's um
they're not operating as essays and some
of them are lease option agreements
two of them are wow dude i have to give
you a respect for that man so what you
say you
you so you've negotiated a bite you have
the option to buy at the end yeah at the
end of the term i'm sick
it's crazy man honestly how did you
negotiate that what happened
okay i'll give you an example of my own
the first one yeah um
so basically the landlord he lives all
the way in canada
okay um so the agent the eastern agent
in coventry they were marketing it for
sale and for rent at the same time
nice yeah i didn't know this i was just
looking for an essay because that time
essay was just like
the thing yeah one month was that this
was
last year october okay cool yeah i think
yeah yeah october last year yeah and
then so that's
um and i went and i went into
i went for the viewing and then i just
asked him he said oh
you know what um he said if you're not
willing to take this as an essay the
landlord's looking to sell it anyway
then i said hang on he's looking to sell
it
that was like we thinking i may be able
to offer something like that
what does samuel normally say in this
situation yeah yeah yeah i
had to gather myself a little bit like
pretend i'm still looking but i was
thinking of what to say
yeah and then i just literally said it
to him
i just said you know what um like you
said i may be able to offer
something like this i said to him what
about
if i rent it
and buy at the same time yeah
but um i said to him the completion
would be
in the next five years or so nice you
know he said he was he was open to the
idea because
he was he said to he said okay he wasn't
really looking to sell it because the
the property was tired anyway yes um
and then so he said he'll go talk to him
and see what happens so when he said
that i was like oh no
he's going to cut me out oh i was like i
was worried that it's not gonna go
yeah he's not gonna pitch it as well as
i thought i would pitch it yeah i'll see
you
this agent pitched it to him yeah wow
i would have been worried as well and
then i was worried so i was like to him
okay talk to him first but then is it
okay if i can also
talk to him after yeah you said okay
yeah that's my problem yeah yeah and
then so when he but when he
pitched it to him the guy called me
straight away just to ask a couple
questions
yeah um i was like you know what i'm not
the right guy to be talking to you
you have to talk to a solicitor bang i
didn't have a sony stuff
you have to talk to somebody yeah but
then um but then i
i explained what i knew yeah of the idea
and then it was like okay well i have
interest why did you do that why did you
not answer his questions and tell him to
speak to your sister because you told me
you shouldn't
yeah absolutely and why that was just
anyone watching this why would you why
would you not
talk to him because they'll have a lot
of questions and you'll be going back
and forth
and a professional is the best player
yeah because if
if you're saying to him yeah i'll buy it
in five years and here's how it works
and this is the insurance so this is the
he might be thinking who's this kid yeah
how can i trust him whereas if you say
to him look i can offer something like
this in principle but the best thing for
you to do sleep on the concept
speak to an independent solicitor yeah
then he speaks this lister
the solicitor does all the selling yeah
right so it's so what you did was just
like
perfect and you deserved the deal you
deserved the deal
okay so then what happened when he spoke
to how did you find solicitor
on facebook okay cool so you just jumped
on on on the groups yeah great you're
good yeah
i posted on your group on average it's
good
easy network so then
you get a solicitor we won't say who you
used because that kind of thing has to
stay within the groups yeah
but um use this lister and then what
happened um
used my solicitor it was closed within a
month yeah great um
got the property got the keys without
before even paying or anything like that
um we did a bit of work attending to nsa
it's doing all right
right yeah great so you've got that now
so so that's not making great
crazy money but it's okay it's washing
his face but is it yeah
yeah he's not losing he's making profit
he's making profit small profit
but what's the what's the deal so how
much do you pay in the landlord
so in total um i'm paying 800 pounds
in total that includes because the flats
it's a bit more expensive
when you do these these options because
you pay um
the mortgage the ground rent yeah and
the service fee
yeah so all of that that's
with ever with it with the so your japan
covers all of that yeah you'll then rent
and this is in birmingham right no no
this isn't coffee industry
i think coventry city is one of it's not
exactly a new build but um
seven years ago okay okay so relatively
new so you're then renting it out
and you're doing that as service
accommodation presumably you've checked
the head lease
yeah yeah there's no mortgage
restrictions so it's all legal
legitimate exactly because people
sometimes think like oh wow this must be
like illegal or no you must that's a
very especially with
when your solicitor is dealing with that
here um
yeah it's all been checked out done
legitimately you're then renting it out
on booking.com yeah booking.com all the
um
sa websites you know the channels airbnb
yeah
how much at the moment listen i know
that right now maybe that strategy in
that area isn't
booming because we're in the middle of a
lockdown but how much profit are you
making i'm just on that one right now
right now about 215. okay so it is cash
flow
it's cash flowing and that'll pick up
man hopefully
it will bro it will bro and you've got
listen if you're
if on booking.com right now in the
middle right now it's november
the middle of a lockdown it's cash
flowing 250 pound a month
when we're allowed to start traveling
again and when tourism picks up and
things pick up
that's gonna that's gonna kill yeah but
the more powerful thing is it's cash
flowing positive
yeah how much are you gonna be how much
did you agree to buy it on the option
for
so but initially it was on the market
for i think around 195
yeah um but because the property was
tired
and and also it had been on the market
for a couple months the landlord started
dropping it yeah dropped it from
literally 10 grand down 185 and then
i offered 175 onto the property so
you're buying it for 175
but in how many years in five years in
five years so again
hopefully in five years it'll be worth a
lot more
which i think it probably will be and
then you can exercise the option at 175
and then you've got the profit the
capital appreciation
basically you're benefiting from that as
if you owned it exactly
you benefit you're getting the growth
you're getting the cash flow
but you didn't you didn't pay a deposit
it's crazy it's a crazy strategy man
yeah i didn't pay anything unlike my
first deal
and you did you say you've got another
lease option just like that yeah but
that's been taken i've given back the
keys now because
um that one wasn't working and it wasn't
working okay
you know what as i always say you're
gonna have properties to over perform
perform and underperform
get rid of the ones that underperform
and keep filling
your pipeline with ones that are going
to overperform okay so overall then how
many how many how many different
properties have you got are you
interested in right now i mean like
read to rent lease options all together
how many is it the ones that i have
yeah and you've got did you see you've
recently just got something going
through as well yeah yeah yeah what's
what's going on
so i've got um it's a four bed in
birmingham yeah um
to planning to turn it into a six bed
yeah um the landlord's already
applied for license so we're just
waiting on that
yeah and then we're going to convert it
into a six bed and
put something in it and put some tenants
into it amazing
dude you've done amazingly well and the
crazy thing is you're just getting
started
yes you are in your mind because i know
when i said to you dude you need to come
on windows wednesday you're making
three over three thousand you were like
oh no i'm not ready nowhere in there
ready
i was surprised to be honest won't be
surprised because i just
you know sometimes you just don't feel
like you're there yet
even though it's the money is there it's
just you've got expenses you know i've
had joint ventures that i've done before
as well that i'm paying off as well so
yeah so you don't feel like you're like
oh my gosh i'm living in louisiana
no but at the same time you're making a
profit
of 3.2 000 a month right yeah so if
you're making a profit of 3.2 000 a
month
that is that's a decent salary and
that's coming in recurring from rent
so it's i think it's phenomenal you're a
young guy early 20s
and um you know it's great talk to me a
little bit about
what what's what's next what's the plan
next because i know you're still
extremely hungry yeah i'm very angry
yeah at this point because
um during the pandemic when when the
essay business collapsed a bit
what my business um was a bit low
um i sort of like went out of it for a
bit yeah
so but now um after watching your videos
again
i've picked it up you're on 365 now i'm
on 365 as well
well talk to me about what 365 is binge
watching those videos
yeah you know i mean like it's good
honestly
for the money that i'm paying it's it's
next to nothing
it's it's honestly worth it yeah um
so i'm gaining as much information as i
can from there
but my my plan is to increase
cash flow yeah so um in the next 12
months or so
yeah i need at least 10.
you know the great thing is i'll give
you some encouragement if you're making
3.2 000 right now
in lockdown your cashflow would increase
automatically as lockdown lifts
that's the first thing i wouldn't rest
though i wouldn't say oh it's going to
increase because
i will still be pushing i'd be getting
more deals
what strategy are you looking at now
you've got rent to rent you've got these
option agreements
what's what's what's the what's next
yeah are you gonna are you not gonna get
into purchasing
that's what i need to get to i'd get
into brr that's that's exactly you
literally took the word out my mouth
you set up a youtube channel to document
the journey what's it called
uh inspire tv with major do that inspire
tv with nigel
do it do you know what i'm gonna leave a
link in the in the channel go
go check it out because honestly dude
i'm so glad to see you winning
you know and and although you might feel
like oh man i'm only making a few grand
a month
and i've had some problems and some
values and oh lock down and yeah
dude like most people would do anything
to be in your situation
and the experience that you've got and
the knowledge that you've got and you've
invested thousands into yourself
yeah you know i know you said the
courses are really cheap which i think
they are
you know honestly they're good value for
money i think so
like it doesn't get any better like you
pay thousands
to go to uni like i went to uni yeah
paid
if i calculated right it's nearly 30
grand yeah
that i'm shooting on whereas your course
yeah you're gonna bear that it is and
and that's why when people say
people that learn about things oh he's
course so expensive i just think well
don't do it then
don't i'm not putting a gun to anyone's
head i'm just offering it but
you know but no i'm really excited i'm
really excited for what you've done so
next
i would say i'll i would recommend do a
little brr deal
pull somebody in on a joint venture
document the heck out of it
on your youtube channel put your money
in pull your money out
and then you've got your cash flow
coming from your renter rents which is
great
but i would now be looking to build
wealth yeah slow pound as well as fast
pound
also what about deal packaging yeah
there's a strategy that i'm interested
in
because you've got you've got the
knowledge like crazy i mean you're
looking at so many different deals
you must come across deals that aren't
good for you i do come across deals or
then just
sell them yeah sell one deal a month
yeah get you an extra three grand a
month coming in
yeah you know so that's definitely what
were you born in zimbabwe yeah how old
were you moved here i was 12 i was 12
years old
my wife moved from zimbabwe when she was
10. oh right yeah she was behind
me but yeah yeah um i mean life over
there is different compared to here
there's so much more opportunities here
it's crazy man
well the economies of always rough right
now i think there's still
massive opportunities there always is
but yeah it's rough
you know so what what brought your
parents over did they come for work or
what
um yeah yeah to be honest for work and
opportunity
um they've you know they're doing really
well for themselves to be honest
and they must be super proud of you well
they
you know like they'd like you to be a
doctor or a lawyer or you go down the
academic group
here here's what it is it's not that
they're not proud yes just
um they haven't they have not seen
the wealth to an extent yeah that
they'll be like oh wow you're doing
something really amazing
right because it's because it's starting
now they just i think that's good
i think that's why you were nervous to
come on windows wednesday
yeah i think it's your parents i think
that's am i right
yeah it is to do with that as well yeah
because i'm like okay i need to prove
myself
at least yeah but you know what you have
proved yourself i'm proud of you
i'm ridiculously proud of you i think
you've done remarkably well i mean
you know who can say at your age you can
say i've got lease option agreements
i've got rent to rent so i've had to
hustle from scratch
you know no no prior property experience
and stuff um are you still you know you
finished now no i finished uni
are you still working on your full-time
property full-time property dude that's
amazing
dude we need to we need to work closely
together yeah just start getting some
things up i would love to do that
let's let's have a conversation
off-camera after this
guys i'm just so impressed with nigel
what
an incredible guy what a humble guy
watch
this space this guy's gonna blow up he's
already
done amazing things you know three to
three point two thousand pounds a month
clean profit full full-time in property
starting with nothing
you know very impressed but watch this
space
if you want to support nigel subscribe
to his youtube channel i'm going to
leave a link
also drop a nice comment in my comment
box as well about nigel
okay there's too many haters in this
world right now too many jealous people
too many people that will try and find a
reason why you know
trying to discredit hard-working
entrepreneurs we need to be supporting
and rooting for hard-working
entrepreneurs in 2020
not trying to tear people down so this
guy is the real deal he's gone through
the training
he's on samuel 365. he's a mentee one
day i'm sure he'll be a mentor
to many people and inspiration to many
people as well so
support him drop a nice comment also if
you want to be in nigel's position
which i know many people do if you want
to be making three point two thousand
pounds a month and full time in property
then you can join samuel 365 is how much
is it 95
a month exactly it's actually one pound
for seven days that's correct it's one
pound for seven days so you can try it
out
and then it's 95 pounds a month there's
no cancellation charges
there's no contracts no funny business
people will tell you that there is
this expensive cancellation judgment
it's all nonsense
try it out pay a pound try it out i'll
leave a description i'll leave it in the
description
i'll leave a link and uh honestly dude
super proud
well done let's work really closely
together over the next 12 months guys
see you next time if you want to see
every week i interview someone on nigel
i got people booked up till after
christmas
and if you want to see how many now
there's well over 100
you want to see well over 100 interviews
like this check out the whole list up
right here
um also you might find it really helpful
to subscribe if you're not subscribed
already you can do that right here
turn the notification bell on i look
forward to seeing you next time